AlAlec Castonguay
ChChantal Hébert
PaPaul Journet
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir (ensemble)
- - Il faut se garder de faire s
cocomparaisons. Monsieur
CaCastonguay aurait aimé mieux
cocommenter une victoire libérae
enen Nouvelle-Écosse.
- - Toute campagne électorale ts
leles symboles sont montés en
épépingle et on essaie de voir
totoutes sortes de signes dans s
fefeuilles de thé. Sa claque
auaurait souhaité que les
lilibéraux, qui était en Nouvel-
EÉcosse au moins une vingtaine :
enen avance, l'emporte.
- - D'une vingtaine de points,
ququand même.
- - Ceci dit, il y a aussi
bebeaucoup de limites à la
cocomparaison. D'abord, c'était
papassé en Nouvelle-Écosse, Yann
ReRenkin, le plus jeune, ce n'et
papas lui qu'on voyait à côté du
mémédecin hygiéniste en chef dea
nonouvelle Écosse. Ce quelqu'un
ququi était relativement peu
coconnu.
- - Ce n'était pas un joueur Koy
CoCovid.
- - Non. Il a une très mauvaise
cacampagne. Les libéraux ont une
mamauvaise campagne. Les limiteà
lala comparaison.
- - Effectivement, il y a de
grgrandes différences, mais cete
rrègle, ce qu'on voyait que le
gogouvernement sortant sortait
gagagnant, là, ça n'arrive pas
cecette fois-ci. Chantal.
- - Il y a une autre règle que
ququand le grondement est rougeà
OtOttawa NETendances on have
d'd'bleu je ne crois pas qu'il
rereste beaucoup de promesses
rorouges après hier soir. C'estn
fafardeau pour l'avoir entendu
popour la première fois en
OnOntario, David Peterson qui un
jojour à part dans les parcelleà
1919 est jamais gagné d'une part
c'c'est un jeu que j'aurais Piee
TrTrudeau cet albatros autour de
momon cou. Bonjour l'ambiance. e
vavais vous suggérer que oui,
c'c'est ce que je t'ai Trudeau
n'n'avais pas de raison de
papavoiser devant ce résultat,
mamais quelque part, il va y avr
dedes stratèges libéraux qui y
trtrouvent quand même leur compe
etet voici pourquoi. C'est un bn
rarappel à tous ces libéraux qui
sosont sur le terrain
cece n'est pas acquis la victoie
élélectorale qui ne peuvent pase
pepermettent à boire du vin blac
dede leur jardin et accroître la
vivictoire dans le sac. À bord
apappel à tout le monde et peut-
êêtre même au premier ministre
lului-même.
- - La dernière fois, on a moins
dede jour pour juger, mais la
dedernière fois on se demandait
s's'il voulait vraiment. Appel x
lilibéraux que la défaite se pet
auaussi.
- - Oui, et notre élection, les
prprogressistes ont moins tendae
àà voter. C'est toujours un défi
paparticulier pour les libérauxt
leles néo démocrate. On le voit,
ququand le taux de participation
esest plus faible, sa tendance à
avavantager les conservateurs et
c'c'est encore plus important
cecette élection car on ne sait
papas dans quelle mesure la
ququatrième vague pouvoir
didissuader les gens d'aller
vovoter. Ce que certains vont
vovouloir rester chez eux?
esest-ce que le vote postal, qui
vava s'en prévaloir.
DoDonc, dans ce sens ça, c'est
vrvrai que ça peut être un rappl
bébénéfique aux libéraux de dire
dede ne rien prendre pour acqui.
MoMoi, la seule leçon que je
titirerai de ce résultat en
NoNouvelle-Écosse que des fois,n
didit que la politique américaie
esest plus intéressante mais ça
rereste du bipartisme et il y a
momoins de mouvements. Nada c'et
pepeut-être ça, il y a beaucoupe
paparties et ça bouge dans les
cacampagnes électorales. Ce quee
reretiens de cette campagne c'et
quque les sondages en début de
cacampagne c'est un Polaroïd qui
pepeut changer c'est comme un
mamatch de hockey, raison pour
lalaquelle on joue, connaissais
papas en avance. Ce n'est pas
énénorme bonhomme avance.
- - Non ce n'est pas énorme.
- - Après avoir trois ou cinq
popoints de pourcentage ça
popourrait surprendre.
- - C'est encore plus dangereux
ququ'un élection on ne sait pas
trtrop comment la définir encore
ilil n'y a pas d'enjeu.
- - Il est au, et tous les parts
vovont vous le dire, je vous
rarappelle ma phrase habituelleà
cece moment-ci à 93, élire un
gogouvernement majoritaire
coconservateur. Commence à
s's'intéresser à la sauce aprèsa
rerentrée, la fête du travail, t
leles débats. Cela dit, il faute
mementionner aussi, c'est
imimportant, le premier ministre
dédésigné en Nouvelle-Écosse,
MoMonsieur Huston, on ne le vera
papasse des tribunes avec Erin
O'O'Toole pour dire que dans les
dedernières années les états
memembres du Parti libéral pour
exexpliquer aux lecteurs de
NoNouvelle-Écosse qu'en votant
popour lui il ne venait pas pour
l'l'sorte du parti conservateuru
gogouvernement fédéral. Il a fat
cacampagne, quand regarde sa
cacampagne, il atteste campagneà
gagauche du Parti libéral.
SuSur le même terrain que Justin
TrTrudeau plutôt que sur le
teterrain d'Erin O'Toole,
tetellement au débat des chefs
leleur reprochait d'avoir trop e
bobonnes choses à dire sur Justn
TrTrudeau.
- - Avec un petit moulin déçu sr
cece début de campagne qu'on
esessaie de dessiner qui n'est s
évévident jusqu'ici.
- - Non, c'est très posé comme
tetemps. Je me suis de la campae
dede 2019 on avait un ton très
agagressif entre les campagnes
coconservatrices et libérales. l
n'n'y avait pas du tout
d'd'affection entre Trudeau et
ShSheer. C'est comme si tout le
momonde sait accompagne séparémt
avavec ses propres thèmes. On st
apappel Athènes, on attend les
ququestions des journalistes por
enenvoyer une petite flèche alo,
enenvoyé une petite flèche à
l'l'autre. On a l'impression que
totout le monde est un
écéchauffement, probablement que
leles électeurs, on a les deux
pipieds sur le bord de la pisci.
CÇa risque d'être une campagneùu
l'l'action va être en courte
pépériode. C'est pas aucune
sesemaine où il y a beaucoup de
momouvements.
- - Je veux donner l'adresse por
leles gens qui veulent envoyer s
ququestions pour le débat des
chchefs. 8 septembre en françai.
BeBeaucoup de gens ont écrit,
cocontinuer, partout au Canada n
vovoulu. Vous pourrez donc poser
dedes questions au chef lors dee
dédébat en français le 8
seseptembre. Dany Fortin, accusé
d'd'agression sexuelle, ça permt
auaussi en campagne rappelée qul
y y avait un gros malaise dans s
FoForces canadiennes. Je vous fs
enentendre les chefs.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef du
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - On a vu un camouflage sur
leles allégations d'inconduite
sesexuelles par le bureau de
M.M. Trudeau il y a 3 ans.
C'C'est totalement inacceptable.
EtEt c'est pourquoi on doit
avavoir une enquête indépendant.
OnOn doit avoir le gel pour les
prpromotions et les augmentatios
dede salaires pour nos officiers
gégénéraux.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - La démonstration a été faite
etet demeure faite qu'au sein
dedes Forces armées canadiennes
pependant longtemps, il y a eu e
esespèce de terrible aveuglement
papar rapport à un nombre qui
apapparaît très élevé de
cocomportements très, très, très
ininappropriés. Et le fait qu'iy
a a un processus judiciaire dans
lele cas présent ne libérera pas
lele gouvernement de devoir rene
dedes comptes.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef, NPD
- - Ce qui est primordial dans
cecette question de ce qui
sese passe dans les Forces
cacanadiennes, c'est vraiment
lele message envoyé aux femmes.
LeLe message qui était envoyé
auaux femmes, c'est : vous n'êts
papas écoutées, vous n'êtes pas
enentendues. On a eu un cas
dede harcèlement sexuel qui état
ararrivé au bureau du premier
miministre, ministre des défens,
etet ils n'ont rien fait.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Parti libéral du Canada
- - Nous avons reconnu depuis le
dédébut qu'il fallait transformr
nonos Forces armées. On a pris
dedes mesures concrètes
dedepuis plusieurs années, mais
évévidemment, il reste énormémet
dede plus à faire, comme on
lele voit. C'est pour ça qu'on
esest très contents d'avoir
lala lieutenante-générale Carign
enen train de mener la bataille
àà l'intérieur des Forces.
- - Bon, est-ce que pour cette
cacampagne électorale, on voit e
lele discours se rassemble,
TrTrudeau dit je demandais
hohonnêtement général l'intérie,
ilil y a aussi un autre examen
exexterne, il n'avait déjà eu u.
QuQu'est-ce que ça change cette
cacampagne?
- - je ne suis pas certain que a
vava être un enjeu central de la
cacampagne électorale. Je n'ai s
l'l'impression que les avaler
vovoter en passant à ça. C'est
clclair que c'est une faiblesse
vrvraiment fédérale. Quand Justn
TrTrudeau dit on a reconnu depus
lolongtemps, c'est vrai. Les
acactions concrètes, ce n'est ps
vrvrai. Ne sait pas céder
susuffisamment de choses dans ls
ceces dernières années pour
vévéritablement prendre ça au
sésérieueux. On a laissé les Fos
cacanadiennes essaie de se
réréformer elle-même en se disat
vontnt faire ça à l'interne, ils
vovont laver leur linge sage en
fafamille et on espère que ça va
bibien se passer. Ça n'a pas été
susuffisant par rapport à ce que
sasavaient être problème dans ls
FoForces canadiennes. Je rappele
quque le ministre de la défenset
miministre depuis que Justin
TrTrudeau est au pouvoir, ça fat
sisix ans. Mais encore aux priss
avavec le même type de controvee
dadans les forces armées
cacanadiennes. Visiblement, il t
ququelqu'un qui n'a pas fait ce
trtravail est probablement le
miministre de la défense. Ce n't
papas terrain agréable pour les
lilibéraux même si je n'ai pas
l'l'impression que c'est quelque
chchose qui va attirer
l'l'attention.
- - Chantal rapidement.
- - Je rappelle que Trudeau, das
leles lettres de mandat qu'il
dodonne à ses ministres, après-
mimidi premier jour, et n'a jams
didit au ministre de mettre en
vivigueur les recommandations du
rarapport Deschamps qui était sr
soson bureau sur ce sujet le jor
ouoù il est arrivé au pouvoir.
- - De rendre à l'extérieur, de
sosortir des forces en examen
cocomplet des plaintes. Paul.
- - Ça écorche image féministe e
JuJustin Trudeau et cela pose la
ququestion de la crédibilité.
PoPourquoi lui faire confiance
trtroisième mandat ce qui n'a ps
fafait dans un premier ou dans n
dedeuxième. C'est assez ironiqu,
enen 2016 il a reçu le rapport
DeDeschamps dont vous avez parl.
CoCondamnation donc créait un
ororganisme fort indépendant.
C'C'est pourtant de mieux
ququantifier le phénomène. Ils t
ririen fait à part en fait mandt
cocommandait un nouveau port qui
ririsque d'arriver aux mêmes
coconclusions. Chose plus
irironique, ils ont décidé de
rerenouveler leur confiance dans
MoMonsieur Hanz, alors qu'il
fafaisait sujet d'allégation. De
llà à renouveler son mandat, ça,
onon aurait très bien pu aller à
l'l'exécutif n'est pas le fairet
nene pas accorder sa confiance à
MoMonsieur Vanz pour gérer le
dodossier honneur de tous les
crcrimes sexuels alors que lui-
mmême faisait l'objet
d'd'allégation. Il y a problèmee
crcrédibilité des libéraux.
- - N'est pas si dur que ça pour
dédémissionner quelqu'un. Pour
rarappel une esquisse de
dédémissionner à ministre des
fifinances en pleine pandémie.
- - Il ne reste trois minutes je
veveux parler de vaccination.
NoNouveau- bonne petite partie s
sasantés avec l'Ontario, si vous
nene voulez pas vous faire
vavacciner vous pouvez vous faie
tetester. Ça devait être le plaB
auau fédéral pour les
acactionnaires. Est-ce que ce
n'n'est pas un bel exemple où ls
dédétails de quelque chose sont
vevenus embêter sérieusement
MoMonsieur Trudeau qui pensait e
c'c'était net histoire
dede tous les fonctionnaires
féfédéraux et la vaccination.
- - Si vous pensez que ça embêtt
jujuste Trudeau, préparez-vous à
cece que ça embête François
LeLegault aussi. Dossier de dire
ouoù on est facile de dire qu'on
esest obligatoire pour la
vavaccination, mais comment en
fafait pour l'appliquer et de
vavaccination obligatoire. J Jue
TrTrudeau a le même problème. Ce
dodoit être obligatoire, et je
dodois mettre des fonctionnaireà
lala porte. C'est plus compliqu.
EsEst-ce que je dois mettre des
momots à la porte, une situation
cocomplexe quand on s'attend au
dédétail. J'étais Trudeau a étée
prpremier à s'avancer. Les
prpremières questions ont été vs
lului. Tenant à Maître Doug For,
FrFrançois Legault, et on n'en a
enencore pour des semaines de
dédébat.
- - Semaine de débat et d'une
sesemaine à l'autre ça se durcit
d'd'une semaine à l'autre.
JuJustin Trudeau, c'est vous
emembarqués pas dans un avion ds
unun train ou dans un autobus
ininterprovincial. Je vous
prprédirai que plus les chiffre,
plplus le nombre de cas va
auaugmenter, plus le discours va
sese durcir.
- - Conclusions.
- - Parce que les gens qui se st
fafaits vacciner devient de mois
enen moins tolérant pas à ceux i
n'n'ont pas fait ce geste-là. De
lala santé je suis certain que s
pepersonnels soignants qui n'ont
papas le goût de travailler avec
dedes gens qui ne sont pas faits
vavacciner. La grande différence
avavec la santé à Québec et les
fofonctionnaires des héros à
OtOttawa que la pénurie de main-
d'd'oeuvre plus vive en santé et
agaggrave les conditions déjà ts
didifficiles. Pe